there have always been people raving on
street corners about the approaching
doom based on the fact that the rise of
Frederick Barbarossa was doing X or Y or
the Emperor Rudolph was doing something
it's very easy to overlay the end time
scenario over any complex period of
history nevertheless i agree with you i
think it's it's very terminal and that
there's a lot of evidence that the
reason the west is so obsessed with
consummation of itself is because the
consummation of the west is actually
built in to our psychology and we keep
trying to do it we tried in the thirty
years war not enough technological push
Hitler tried to do it close but no
banana now now the next try we have this
Ragnarok this wish for an operatic
conclusion it's kind of infantile ism we
are so frustrated by how it doesn't work
that the lead we want a deus ex machina
ending that leaves everyone satisfied so
you can just he'll leave the theater
completely
ah there was justice retribution Daniel
ma all these things